it was billed as the eighth wonder of
the world illegitimate and giant of a
man
seven foot four inches tall and more
than 500 pounds Andre the Giant was the
greatest attraction the world of
professional wrestling has ever seen yet
his appeal went far beyond the ring with
his humble manner in his boundless charm
Andre became one of the most famous and
recognizable athletes on the planet and
a genuine cultural phenomenon yes behind
the celebrity Andre was a man trapped
inside a world he never created and one
that would ultimately destroy him the
man we know as Andre the Giant entered
the world as Andre Aranea rossum off on
May the 19th 1946 his father Boris had
migrated from Belgium to France in 1934
settling in more neon just outside of
Paris in 1938 Boris had married Mary Ann
a petite Polish woman who soon began
producing offspring Andre it became the
middle of five children Boris was a
strong stout man who stood just over six
feet tall he worked the land as a farmer
and soon put his children to work
cutting firewood tending the stock and
otherwise getting their hands dirty at
birth Andre was 11 pounds but there were
no signs of abnormal growth during his
first six years known as DD as a result
of his system is pronouncing his name he
was a healthy good-looking and charming
child but as he grew older his rate of
physical growth outstripped that of his
peers this was especially noticeable in
his face where his jaw and forehead
became unusually pronounced at age six
Andre began attending school as a nearby
Lucy some more he loved the social
interaction and proved to be a good
student especially excelling at
mathematics already he towered over the
other children not only those in his
grade but also those in any great he
dominated in most sports invariably
finding himself in the position of
goalie on the soccer field with his
large hands and long limbs it was
virtually impossible to get the ball
past him by the age of 10
Andre stood at six feet tall and tipped
the scale at around 200 pounds he looked
and
moved like a full-grown man on the farm
his father had discovered he could do
the work of three boys his age so Boris
took him out of school and put him to
work full-time on the farm the Rossum
office had little in the way of material
possessions they were a close family and
the children were raised with love and
dignity though they simply learned to
accept what came without complaint
so when Andre was taken from school
although he missed the mental
stimulation and the association with his
schoolmates he threw himself into the
life of a farmer sure that this was to
be his lot the physical labor
coupled with Andres unnatural growth
potential allowed him to develop a level
of physical strength that stunned
onlookers by the age of 15 he was able
to lift a car so that his brother could
change the tire without having to worry
about a wheel Jack it was around the age
of 16 though that Andres growth spurt
went to a whole new level
his height quickly approached 7 feet and
his weight went into the 300s but his
parents they were not overly concerned
about his growth spurt and Andre was
never taken to see a doctor
during his mid-teens Andre began a
woodworking apprenticeship after two
years of diligent application and study
he decided the trade was not for him and
went to work at a factory that made hay
baling engines but the monotony of
working on an assembly line was worse
than what had previously been doing
Andre had dreams of doing something
different he just didn't know what that
was with no other options he went back
to work for his father on the farm by
now his incredible size was constantly
drawing attention and he became known as
a local curiosity by the time he was 18
his fame had spread as far as Paris
there was a wrestling promoter who got
to hear about the teenage giant who was
stronger than three men he took the trip
to Milan and knocked on the Rossum
office door he told Boris and Marianne
that their son had a future in wrestling
and the potential to make many francs
with his parents consent Andre began
learning the fundamentals of wrestling
and was taken under the wing of Montreal
born wrestler and promoter Frank Valois
he began on the Parisian wrestling
circuit under the ring name of Javert in
honor of a mythical French Giants
[Music]
quandry worked as a furniture mover
during the day in order to cover his
expenses in Paris after work he could be
found in a wrestling gym slowly
developing his craft
even though pro wrestling then as now
was more entertainment than sport it was
still necessary for Andre to learn the
basic moves Falls and holds that would
create the illusion of violence while
keeping him from injury however with his
intimidating size and strength it was
hard to find an opponent who was willing
to share the ring with him as a result
progress was slow despite this his sheer
size and power ensured that he never
lost in the ring
in 1965 Andre received a notice to
report to the Army's draft board when he
turned up for his physical exam the
recruiters could hardly believe what
they saw a 19 year old who stood over
seven feet tall and weighed 350 pounds
despite his incredible strength and good
health he was deemed unfit for service
for the simple reason that the army did
not have any uniforms or shoes that were
big enough for him back in Paris Andre
met Eduardo Carpentier a popular
montreal-based Canadian wrestler asking
the older man to train him Andre spent
the next two months learning valuable
ring tips from the veteran before
leaving for home Carpentier advised
Andre to get in the ring as much as
possible and build experience he also
promised that he would one day bring
Andre over to North America where
wrestling was much bigger than it was in
Europe meanwhile Andre continued paying
his dues on the European circuit he
traveled around Europe and even as far
as Africa developing a huge following
crowds were overwhelmed by his sheer
physical size then as the match began
they were delighted to see how he
overwhelmed his opponents in 1969 Andre
ventured off the European continent to
wrestle in New Zealand where he was
billed as monster Eiffel Tower then he
went on to Japan where he competed with
an American partner in the IWF world tag
team champs the pair won the title and
suddenly Andre was a world champion it
was while he was in Japan that Andre was
diagnosed via doctor with the condition
that had caused his unusual growth this
condition was acromegaly it's a rare
disorder of the pituitary glands which
leads to the overproduction of human
growth hormone it was caused by a benign
tumor which if it develops before bone
growth was complete would lead to
gigantism the doctor also informs Andre
that lai fixed
agency for people with the condition was
40 years Andre told no one about his
diagnosis keeping the secret that at 20
his life was more than likely already
half over
but this knowledge undoubtedly spurred
him on to reach the top of his chosen
profession as quickly as he possibly
could
having now won a world wrestling title
he felt he had sufficiently paid his
dues and was ready to take on the
Americans from Japan he travelled to
Canada where he met up with Eduardo
Carpentier very became part of the
Montreal based chrome Prix wrestling
circuit quickly making a name for
himself on the basis of his size charm
and surprising agility in the ring he
would often be paired against two or
even three opponents at a time in
one-on-one matches he took on undefeated
such canadian luminaries as killer
Kowalski and butcher Vautrin in the same
time as he was wrestling in Canada on
Terry made frequent trips back to Japan
where he was immensely popular there he
won the international Wrestling
Federation's World Series defeating
established stars like Karl Gotch and
Billy Robinson in the process Andres
hard work in the ring was establishing
him as a top international draw cart in
1971 he was named Rookie of the Year by
the wrestling yearbook 1972 his biggest
match to date came in May 1972
when he was pitted against the six foot
nine Mormon giant Don Leo Jonathan in
what was billed as the match of the
century with 20,000 people on hands the
match set an indoor wrestling attendance
record now this match was going on Dre's
way until he lost his temper and thrust
his giant hands around Leo's neck when
his locker room guys ran in to stop him
from choking out his opponents Andre
tossed them aside like ragdolls
eventually order was restored and Andre
was disqualified he had lost the match
but he had also established one of his
key gimmicks he was a lovable Giants but
if you make him mad he would turn into a
killer after the bout with Donnelly Oh
Andre began adventuring south to the
United States where he would appear as a
special attraction on the American
Wrestling Association carts now it was
time to reach out to the biggest player
in the market Vincent J McMahon of the
World Wrestling Federation
Vince McMahon was first introduced to to
the man who became his greatest
superstar in June of 1973 until then
Andre had been wrestling under the name
of Javert McMahon's first move was to
rebrand the chance no one in American
knew whose affair was but they could all
relate to Andre the Giant's now as well
as changing the name McMahon also
modified Andres onstage approach up
until now he had shown remarkable
athleticism now here was to rely solely
on his overwhelming size and bulk to
defeat his opponents Andres first match
under the WWF banner took place on March
the 26th 1973 he easily defeated buddy
wolf at Madison Square Garden the
American audience had never seen
anything like this giant of a man and he
was immediately a sensation McMahon well
he knew a good thing when he saw it
booking Andre to perform night after
night all over the country by keeping
the big man moving McMahon was able to
prevent the novelty of the gentle giant
from wearing off everywhere he went
Andre shattered box-office records
McMahon was careful however not to pit
him against other top drawers for fear
of damaging their prestige as his
popularity extended beyond the wrestling
community
Andre began to receive offers for TV
appearances in the late 1970s he
appeared on The Tonight Show and the
Merv Griffin Show and was featured in
such magazines as Sports Illustrated and
people in 1976 Hollywood came calling
the writer of the most popular show on
television the Six Million Dollar Man
had decided to capitalize on the string
of Sasquatch reporting's that had
recently been made they knew that there
was only one man who could realistically
play the 8-foot tall forest creature and
so it was that Andre donned a fur
covered suit and prosthetic makeup and
battles Lee Majors as millions watched
on television to the horror of his
legion of preteen fans the Six Million
Dollar Man was treated like a rag doll
by the Sasquatch Andre followed up his
first acting role with a mixed
discipline match fighting boxer Chuck
Wepner in June of 1976 at New York's
cher Stadium the match was a knockoff of
Muhammad Ali's famous match
with Japanese wrestler Antonio Inoki
Wepner had won fame as the only man to
knock down Ali and had been Sylvester
Stallone's inspiration for Rocky
the match began with weapon a taunting
Andrei while circling him and throwing
out a few jabs which the towering
wrestler simply ignored he was well
aware that he could drop Wepner at any
moment but wanted to give the audience
their money's worth however in the third
rounds Wepner managed to get a shot in
that connected with Andres face and it
was this that got the big man's
attention
Andre snorted and then hit Wepner with
an inverted atomic drop and a headbutt
he then picked the six foot three inch
Wepner up like a rag doll and threw him
over the top rope the match with Wepner
had been a fast but it further cemented
the legend of Andres invincibility in
1977 he was listed as Pro Wrestling
Illustrated most popular wrestler
promoters from all over the world
pleaded for him to come over and face
off with their champion
[Music]
Andre had many hyped rivalries and
matchups during the period of the late
1970s perhaps the greatest was with
Ernie big cat lat
the 6 foot 9 315 pounds Ladd was a
four-time all-star defensive tackle who
went on to become a career wrestler he
developed a very arrogance persona and
has a penchant for sticking his thumb in
the eyes of his opponents as a result he
was hugely unpopular and the perfect
foil for Andre the two wrestled
regularly across the country in matches
billed as battle of the Giants in 1980
Vince McMahon paired
Andre up with an up-and-coming wrestler
who had formerly been a bodybuilder his
name was Terry the lair but his WWF
stage name was Hulk Hogan McMahon head
him up with a theatrically sleazy
manager by the name of classy Freddie
Blassie
Hogan Blasi were marketed as the
ultimate cheat team and the ideal
antagonists for the by-the-book Andre
the tactic worked a treat with Hogan
becoming the most hated bad guy in WWF
history at 330 pounds Hogan marched his
way through the Federation's lesser
stars the fans demanded a matchup with
Andre and in March of 1980 McMahon made
it happen
despite his in character bravado Hogan
was terrified to match up against Andre
the very thought of working match with
the giant made him physically ill the
matchup that resulted seriously injured
Hogan he recalled that Andre messed up
my shoulder screwed my neck up and
suplexed me on the head
it seemed became clear that Andre had a
personal dislike for Hogan they traveled
together to Japan for a series of
matches as they went around the country
Andre continued to taunt the young
wrestler sitting in the back of the bus
so that he could bounce his empty beer
cans off the back of Hogan's head Hogan
accepted the humiliating treatment as
something of a rite of passage by the
age of 34 Andre had become the biggest
thing in the world of wrestling but to
those outside of that world he was
generally seen as little more than a
sideshow freak he was constantly
subjected to the stairs and jeers of the
public and then there were the
discomforts imposed by his gargantuan
frame he suffered from agonizing back
pain and joint ailments and he could
never find a chair or a bed that
provided anything approaching comfort
and of course always in the back of his
mind was the knowledge that his time was
running out
he wasn't meant to make it past 40
Andres appetite for food was impressive
but it was nothing compared to his
liking for alcohol
he loved French wine who would often
drink an entire case before lunch during
more than one all-night drinking session
he would knock back in excess of a
hundred handles of beer and even after
this he would show little sign of
drunkenness Andre and Hogan continued in
their ring feud through the end of 1980
drawing huge crowds but by the next year
Hogan had left the WWF over a
disagreement with McMahon over his role
in rock III
as a 1981 began Andre it was at the top
of his game his rivalry with Hogan was
soon replaced with an ongoing feud with
the Mongolian giant-killer Khan in a
match in 1981 Karn brought Andre to the
canvas sleeping with Jones unable to get
up his ankle had snapped Andre was out
for several weeks and the storyline was
hyped that he was out for revenge they
met again on July the 20th 1981 but the
match ended in a double disqualification
Andre went on to dominate through the
early to mid 80s on April the 7th 1986
he prevailed in a 20-man battle royale
to come off the victor at WrestleMania 2
following WrestleMania 2 Andre took a
break from wrestling after a decade and
a half in the ring his body it was
breaking down the health effects of his
disease were also compounding during
this period he was given a part in the
Rob Reiner directed movie The Princess
Bride he played the role of the lovable
giant Fezzik in what has become a cult
movie classic returning to the WWF in
1987 Andre faced up to his old nemesis
Hulk Hogan he was also back in the WWF
Falls at WrestleMania 3 andrei weighed
in at 520 pounds this put a huge strain
on his joints and his lower back causing
constant pain in the final matchup
Hogan defeated Andre with what became
known as the body slam heard around the
world
Hogan tore is latissimus dorsi muscle in
the monumental effort required to hoist
the giant overhead Andre though he got
his revenge in a rematch that was aired
on the main event in February of 1988 he
defeated Hogan and took the WWF World
Heavyweight Championship
from him
Andre went on for another four years but
he wasn't the wrestler that he had been
in the past
his body was wracked with pain sometimes
to the point that he couldn't stand
without leaning on the ropes
Andre owned a ranch in ellaby North
Carolina and spent more and more time
there as his health deteriorated he was
there in January of 1993 when he heard
that his father had died back in France
he hopped on the next plane in order to
attend the funeral after the funeral he
stayed on to spend time with his mother
and siblings on the night of January the
27th he died in his sleep as a result of
congestive heart failure
his mother intended to bury him
alongside his father but Andre had
recently revised his will stating that
he wished to be cremated in accordance
with his wishes his ashes were returned
to the United States and scattered on
the grounds of his ranch at ellaby back
in America and around the world millions
of fans mourned the loss of the biggest
and baddest man do you ever step into
the ring so I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographic s-- if you
did there's a couple of things you could
do right now one is hit that like button
below also if you want more stuff like
this we put out brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday so hit that
subscribe button below and subscribe
button doesn't do what it used to on
YouTube if you actually want to get a
notification about these videos please
do hit that Bell button next to the
subscribe button and that will send you
a notification every time every Monday
and Thursday won't put out a new video
also if you want to watch something else
right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]
you